the first trailer for the upcoming
marvel studios secret and raging tv show
has just released and i gotta say guys
this show is actually going to be insane
i reckon it's a potential to be the best
marvel tv show today just because of how
different it is in the sense of it's a
more serious and grounded show has a
much darker tone unlike previous marvel
tv shows movies such as love and thunder
which was
very opposite of a serious movie let's
just say that there was a lot of jokes
it was a very light-hearted and just not
taking itself too seriously unlike this
show secret invasion which has very much
taken itself seriously the dialogue is
very good the acting is very good and
the tone and the music just everything
about it from what we've seen in this
trailer is very good in a sense of
taking itself serious target audience of
this doesn't seem to be targeted at kids
which i'm really excited about because
i'm a big fan of darker shows like this
one and this trailer doesn't even
contain a single joke so my only hope is
that the show is exactly like this
trailer and this trailer isn't
misleading in any way but from rumors
that i have heard it looks like it will
be this serious show that we've all
wanted so let me know what you guys
think of this in the comment section
below are you guys excited for the show
are you glad we're getting a more
serious and grounded show like this one
and you haven't already please do
consider subscribing thanks for watching